so a lot of people have asked me for
more foreign film reviews the fact of
the matter is I try to only see ones
that I know or really think are going to
be really good and I am so glad that I
chose the hunt the hunt stars Mads
Mikkelsen you may know him from films
like Valhalla Rising directed by Nicolas
Winding Griffon or Christina Royale asla
shieff and he's currently playing
Hannibal on the NBC TV show he's a
terrific actor he's actually one of my
favorite actors and in this film he
plays a teacher a very innocent minded
teacher he's a good man and you really
feel for the guy in this movie they
really did a good job of setting up this
character as somebody that you really
liked and he wouldn't mind getting to
know in real life it's clear that he's
recently separated or divorced from his
wife because custody of his son is an
issue he's hoping that his son can come
and live with him soon his son does want
to come and live with him he's starting
up a new relationship all the kids in
the school love him until one little
girl decides to tell a little lie
this little girl falsely accuses him of
sexual molestation and because of that
his entire life crumbles to the ground
despite the fact that there actually
isn't any evidence supporting this
everything about his life changes for
the worst and you get to see what it
would be like for a man or woman who was
falsely accused of something like this
trying to defend themselves and the idea
of how a rumor can literally ruin your
life even if it's not true the hunt is
one of the best films I have seen this
year I loved every second of it about 30
minutes into this movie once the plot
really kicked in I literally sat forward
in my seat and I almost stayed
motionless throughout the entire film I
was gripped from almost beginning to end
of this movie honestly there were
moments in this movie that were so
emotionally powerful that were so
incredibly acted and performed that I
was on the edge of my seat and nothing
ever happens that there's no big action
scene there's no amazing special effects
it's just pure raw emotion delivered so
powerfully especially by Mads Mikkelsen
who I honestly think deserves a Best
Actor nomination this movie just
solidifies the fact that I really loved
that guy as an actor he can inhabit so
many different characters because before
this he was really well known for
playing those kind of dark evil
characters and with a role like this
where he gets to really play your normal
everyday guy who has to deal with
something truly horrible happening
he shined in this role he was just
excellent all the actors in the film
were so believable
there wasn't that scene where you felt
like they were overdoing it just to be
noticed you know anytime in this film
where an actor would have you know one
of those big meaty scenes or you can
tell okay this is the scene where
everything happens it didn't feel like
hey look at me I'm an actor
and I'm good at what I do it felt
completely real and that's because the
screenplay for this film was so
meticulously crafted to be realistic
there isn't that big monologue scene
where it's like we're in a movie now so
let's be actors and say like this great
big speech everything was how I could
imagine it being if you were falsely
accused of something like this one of
the best compliments that I can give a
foreign film is that I forget about the
subtitles I forget about the foreign
language I think I'm just watching these
events and I almost don't even pay
attention to the subtitles they just
read themselves that's how interested I
was in the hunt the subtitles just came
into my brain it's like I wasn't even
trying to read it I wanted to hear each
word out of these characters mouth I
wanted to see where each character was
gonna go and I was so invested in each
one of them it's been a really long time
since I felt so into a character and I
wanted him to be okay and I really
wanted to comfort this guy and I just
wanted everything to work out my only
issue with the film is that the last
like 15 minutes of it did one of those
things were okay we're going to traverse
a long period of time really fast here
and I feel like that was a little easy a
little simple it didn't really bother me
that much but for that reason I'm going
to give the hunt in a I really think
it's an emotionally powerful movie I
think if you get a chance to see it it
is playing a limited release in America
right now I know it's been out in other
countries for a long time but the u.s.
is just now getting it it's terrific I
loved it please check it out but beware
this is not a popcorn movie not a
popcorn movie this is definitely an
intense and disturbing film emotionally
but it is terrific and I loved it so
guys have you seen the hunt I'd be
interested in knowing what you thought
of it as always if you liked this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes